all right hello everyone hope you guys
are having a wonderful day and today we
are here with episode number 18 of noob
with Mill so basically uh going to get a
lot done in this episode it's the first
episode since I've been off school so it
may come out actually a little earlier
than the rest but starting off right now
with a 210 mil Bank pretty much um if
you guys don't know I started off with a
Mill and a pretty shite account a long
while ago and we have progressed this
thing significantly um right now I'm
about 40K away from 99 strength not
going to go ahead and get that right
away I'm waiting for one one of my
friends to get on like one of my good
friends in game going to go ahead get it
on him but to start off we are going to
go ahead and upgrade another ring so
Sears ring done going to go ahead and uh
start up my neck reels task now that I
have 75 defense for The Bu work and a
Sears ring eye so little bit of gear
progress well feel like an idiot I was
supposed to just be working on this
video and I just went ahead and
accidentally got 99 stke
I was supposed to do that some other
time but it is what it is God damn it
this is going to be in my new with the
Mills Aries and this video as well so
[__] all right so at this point I kind
of need to go over some of the merch
I've been up to so this was a little
while ago I think it was earlier today
but I went ahead and got a 600k margin
on a third age ROP top and then from
there just a lot of stuff so two rings
of suffering that end up selling off for
200k profit each that's 400k um a 's
bull work as you guys can see right
there I merged for 150 two more rings of
suffering right here and right here that
I also sold on for 200k profit another
two that I then sold off for another
200k profit and then three more that I
sold on for 125k profit so with that
said so we had six that sold on for 200k
profits which means 1.2 mil the Den's
bull work was like 1.3 or 130k is or
160k and then we have the almost 400k
that made up here so all in all it's
around I think like 1.7 1.8 mil in
merchesi did wake up at one point during
the night I guess so I ended up doing
this merch which was a 1.2 mil
ancestrial robot a merch nothing too
shabby there I did have to sell off some
things to be able to afford it but
obviously turned out to be worth it and
here we go actually getting from 76 to
77 crafting solely un stringing jewelry
which is pretty impressive feat uh with
that said 263k away from 93 magic here
we are feels like it's been forever but
I've been working on videos recently and
the neck reel task doesn't allow me to
AFK so kind of push that off for a while
but we are 66k away from 93 magic now
that was a really good task and I
actually did some testing for a video
and found out that ice bursting here is
actually profitable which was a little
surprising but let's get another task
crazy archaeologist of course I'm taking
35 of those should be a pretty lit time
let's go ahead and get some kills boys
and here we go done with the clue scroll
so time to go ahead and open it I'm a
big baller so I'll do it in the Wy no
worries 24 sweets yeah decent amount of
cash off that I guess so I've never
really had a collection or anything
going and this guy wanted me to go ahead
and start one so if you guys ever see me
in game or ever want to get in contact
with me and throw me some things go
ahead and uh just throw me any sort of
alcohol we'll keep a little we'll keep a
little tab going for the uh for the
people and another hard casket um this
is why I ended up doing the one before
the crazy archaeologist task cuz I
thought maybe I could get a hard clue
while I was killing crazy archaeologist
I did and three run full Helms really
all right well back to Crazy
archaeologist hey there we go that's why
I do these tasks so far we've gotten
three shards within 54 kills I think I
got my other ones at like 18 KC and 19
KC I don't know how much of this
actually will sell on for
ooh 1.5 mil let's get it and there we go
another test done sorry if there's any
background noise but as you guys saw
odium Shard just insane um I don't have
all the loot here but I'll go ahead and
price check some of it I'll take out the
blood runes we'll go ahead and say addon
I don't even it's 1.5 mil plus the 300K
probably I'll take this out there we go
so yeah we have 3K plus a 1.5 to 1.6 mil
so it's over a 2 mil task which is
pretty impressive just obviously cuz I
got lucky
uh from there go ahead and get some cave
hes maybe now we'll get our first black
mask just maybe all right I take that
back I actually have been looking at
this like efficient Slayer kind of chart
I kind of want to go off of it just for
a little bit I know I'm not the most
efficient uh person in the game but I
figure I'll go ahead and try give it a
little bit of an effort and uh yeah so
[__] uh it says to skip jadas as well
but I'm obviously going for the pet so
I'll go ahead and do it all right here
we go uh I know I do a lot of bond
giveaway in my videos and sometimes you
guys may be like does he actually give
away the money and there you go buddy
hopefully you enjoy that somehow I
managed to get that kill my internet
right now is terrible but no pet it
doesn't look like on the kill no nothing
there so on the exchange can we get
anything I'm here for 31 and okay kill
count number 11 actually I said 11 I
meant 13 didn't even realize that was
our 300th task and we got 300 points um
I would have went to Durell had I known
but I did not and 132 black demons
pretty good going to do these in the
catacombs but before that actually we do
have a totem to use so I think I'm going
to go do that okay here we are went
ahead and used a totem uh I know there's
four little things over here but I
didn't have to take down anyone it's
relatively quick kill and uh nothing of
note here and another casket thank you
sco and uh well we got the hard clue
count up and there we are done with the
black demon task so I did actually go
ahead and use these bracelets for the
first time ever I think that they are a
good use here um also on top of that
ended up getting 77 attack and are on
our way to 90 a Slayer but with that
said 63 Anu should be a quick task and
here we go Tas number 302 done anus
hopefully something decent yes I mean
I'm I mean I might as well God damn and
there we go done with the neck reels
test so you guys may notice something a
little different actually I'm on this
account already but I was using my main
account to go ahead and just lure uh
neck reels for my Noob account really
really good stuff honestly like it's
just insane that these things are
actually profitable and oh so nice man
so nice so yeah as you guys can see here
we got 1.5 to 1.6 million loot this is
from like an hour and I do have some
stuff on my newb account as you guys can
see over here I had a little bit of
runes but other than that I mean it was
really nice I was using the imbued I was
getting around 65k Slayer XP per hour
along with 220 to
230k um mag XP so that I mean that was
great I did hit 93 magic while I was
doing it and I'm already like 25% of the
way to 94 so if I can get another next
task or maybe a dust Devil's task that'd
be really lit and time for another task
so squas not bad good exp we'll take it
I guess um as far as Slayer goes though
63k man man and another kill of
disappointment [__] I have a hard clue
on me I should have oh I hate
myself damn it Shield left half nothing
else going on really yeah nothing else
damn it I should have done the hard clue
first [__] finish off the clue scroll
and oh we got two pages that's actually
a decent clue scroll we got armadel page
four and sidan page two good old 400k
we'll take it try to ignore the Barking
Dog you may hear in the background but
finish off the squas task and 40 black
dragon kbd here we come give me the pet
give me it and another hard clue
scroll yeah and kbd task done nothing of
note this time we actually didn't get
that many U drops or gold or drops or
really anything but we go ahead and get
ourselves a hellhound task while I
usually do them I've recently found out
that you should cancel them um I guess
for whatever sort of efficiency um you
should cancel these as well uh lots of
things to learn lots of things to do but
just trying to get a decent task you
know okay as far as efficiency goes also
supposed to cancel these but you know I
like to be a rule breaker every now and
then finished off my wyvern's task I
actually just did it with range because
I just had the gear so I was like why
not makes it a lot easier but there's
the total loot of the task cool little
650k didn't take all that long uh time
to get another task Cal fights Jesus
Christ I've always questioned whether or
not that is possible to love and uh
after using these bracelets I would have
to say yes I've learned that it is
possible yeah you guys just watch me
teleport away from my task when I still
had two left okay well there we go after
uh you know just walking back and
getting one more kill we went ahead and
finish that off uh fire Giants of course
I'll do them whatever task number 308
done time for another one oh my
God all right here we go 90 Slayer and
and gone just like that g to get 94 HP
here in a second though but 90 Slayer
really cool dark Beast if I ever do
morning M part to I think that's a quest
for it so who knows somehow I just
missed the level like no no explanation
I've been sitting here I've been ready
but uh yeah 94 HP 108 combat moving on
up but attack's really what we're
focused on and caly test nice and easy
just done gargoyles gargoyles are cancel
test I think it might block them once I
get to 200 or should I unblock [__] I
probably unblock spiritual creatures and
just block gargo forever since they seem
to be pretty commonly assigned and I am
not about it at all so go ahead oh [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] assignment oh
God I could do some sire [__] [__] [__]
[__] what do I do what do I do I don't
know I'll probably just do them in the
[__] catacombs cuz I hate
myself let's go first whip on the
account
boys let's go that's sick
what what and time for another task so I
actually did God damn it time for
another task I actually did get a whip
which is pretty nice um also a shield
left half which isn't worth a whole lot
but I mean in total we probably made
like 2 mil on this granted I'm not
taking into account the like 100k that
maybe we spent on prayer potions but not
too bad definitely happy about the whip
drop uh now hell hounds uh apparently
you're supposed to skip hellhound so
I'll go ahead and do that it's fine by
me I might do them in the future just
for hard Clues but God damn it I always
misclick man and 43 black dragons oh man
we are going back we are going back to
kbd and there we go another sco done got
all of these shards from my abysal demon
task and just just the plate skirts
again man and I forgot to do the hard
clue again God damn it forget every time
done with the black dragon test so we
hit 500 KC overall really nice really
nice uh decent loot decent loot uh no
thank you okay it's time to skip that
not doing any steel dragons would be
kind of quick I guess fire Giants
whatever I can AFK them so I have done a
couple things I just finished off my
greater demon task I've reorganized the
bank which is actually a little
different you guys see that here in a
second I guess as far as the video goes
uh also went ahead got myself almost 62
farming going start doing Farm runs
again along with 79 attack so let's go
ahead and get ourselves another task
that is like the third time in a row I
think I've come to get a task and I've
gotten a steel dragon task that's
ridiculous okay that's fine we can do a
Jad task good luck I'm pet all right
well I accidentally just streamed this a
second ago rather than recording it so
you guys didn't get to see it but I
finished off uh fairy tale part two this
gave me 2011 Quest points which allows
for another block task it also allowed
me to complete my hard clue which I went
ahead and got a run kite Shield magic
short bow and I think like 14k off of so
yeah nothing too great and yeah
accidentally walked in there without my
blowpipe then left then realized that
that cancels the task so uh yeah that's
great blood felds they added more in the
catacombs I'll go ahead and do them done
with another task finished off my blood
felds um the only reason I did this is
just so I get totem pieces I got one so
I guess we'll call it a win but time for
another task and disgusting guess I'll
go ahead and record for what I ended up
getting from that task as well just loot
wise not the pickaxe um everything else
though we made a decent amount of profit
I me 300K minus like 10 prayer potions
cool 250k these bracelets are the Savior
Slayer I'm happy I started using them
makes a Tas go a little quicker [__]
like that 51 Anu I'll do that real quick
God damn it yeah Anu task went by pretty
easily also use some more of the
bracelet abysal demons okay I'll take
them I'll take them I mean I'm not doing
sire because I just oh s pisses me off
and I wasn't expecting this at all but I
just got an Abyssal head I think they're
one in 6K I I don't know I looked it up
I thought that's what I saw that's
insane if that's true but there we go
could get the red Slayer Helm now if I
want but holding out of them Claws and
done with the Abyssal demons task not a
whole lot going on we did get a top and
a middle though which kind of nice one
Superior only got the top from it uh
fire Giants I did some of these earlier
I kind I'm kind of feeling a decent task
so chaos Elemental yes yes it's like a
one and four or it's one in I think it's
one and 350 for the pet so like that's
like a 10% chance or [__] five I don't
know whatever let's go ahead and do it
I'm going to go do a skzo kill right now
another skzo kill done uh yeah just R
plate bodies we also got a hard clue
this time because uh I remembered to
actually do it and another hard clue
scroll all right I mean it's almost 100K
so we'll take it that's fine and I think
that's where we're going to go ahead and
end off the episode episode so before we
do going to go ahead and look through
the Grand exchange real quick so this is
5 mil here however it's now changed to
about 2 mil so not that great uh in
total in here we probably have like 2
mil and 200k or so on the person we have
nothing made a lot of progress this
episode but let's see how it turns out
in cash flow so let's go ahead and use
conduit and it'll tell us our bank value
and here we go calculating and okay it's
going to take a little longer than I
thought 218 mil add on the 2 mil 200k in
the bank that's
22.5 mil so that is not bad at all
really excited about that actually I
didn't think I would actually have done
that well but we're getting there that
whip drop helps out a lot oh so glad to
finally have Slayer be profitable uh
next episode I think we're going to go
ahead start off with the chaos Elemental
and probably start unlocking Zora I mean
at this point like how haven't I done it
yet but with that said that'll be it for
this video hopefully you guys enjoyed if
you guys did make sure to leave a like
if you guys have anything you guys want
to go ahead and tell me comment that
down below if you guys enjoy the content
make sure to sub to the channel and uh
yeah with that said hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace next
[Music]
me